nothing improves in life unless if you
inspect it regularly and I mean nothing
so take any area of your life for me
I'll give you an example 90 days ago I
did not like where I was at with my body
weight and my energy I weighed 257
pounds and I've never made 257 pounds
ever I went to a doctor we spent 4 hours
together we did testing we got every
single thing I can get on myself my body
fat percentage my body mass index water
you know how much fat my body carries
what muscle do I need to have every
single dick triglycerides every single
detail we can possibly do
he made the recommendations
recommendations were made I'm supposed
to implement with the recommendations
that were made so whatever those
recommendations were no grains no you
know all this other stuff that I went
through
fast forward 90 days later I won this
morning I ended up losing 24 pounds I'm
at 233 right now haven't weighed 233
since 2006 but the reason why that have
my energy is just off the charts why
because I inspected it if I don't
inspect it that's not going to happen
the same goes with your relationships
the same goes with your business the
same goes with your life the same goes
with your finances back in the days in
2003 my credit score was terrible every
single month I mean every single month I
started running my credit score every
month on the 19th of the month I ran my
credit score every month I read all my
reports and found out what wasn't
supposed to you under what was your two
years three years later my credit score
went from a 489 to an 822 why again
expecting so today I'm going to talk
about how to inspect your business again
this question is probably one of the
most common comments that we get Pat how
do you inspect your business now prior
to me getting into this I want to tell
you I got a surprise for you at the end
because this actually requires you to
have a PDF to print out and have access
to so stay tuned watch the entire video
because you do want to have this PDF to
do it exactly with your own business
that I'll tell you how I do it myself
it's a very very extensive PDF that'll
help you out with so inspecting your
business how often do I do this I do
this full day once a year and another
time per use like every six months or so
I'll do it for half a day we'll sit down
we'll go through
few things on what we need to improve
and we'll improve it but once a year
when I inspect this is a full day maybe
two days that will inspect it for the
business and then it's multiple
businesses and it's multiple parts of my
life when I do my life planning in my
business planning so let's get right
into it how to inspect your business
first of all there are 12 different
categories that I have here and every
one of them is tied to a number and a
goal every single one of them so you see
on the left side here's numbers and
goals and then here is a different
categories to inspect within your
business
I'll explain every single one of them -
and I'll tell you how I do this so first
one is team what is a team so when I
look at my team who do I need Who am I
missing
what department needs help what
department needs a leader
what department needs support what
department doesn't need people what
department do I need to fire the weakest
link that slows everybody else down but
I look at the team within different
departments what I look at my team I
score the team between 0 to 10 how good
do you feel about your team now by the
way you can score teams and getting even
more detailed your team could be your
assistant your team could be you know
your executives your Salesforce you're
coming in many different things but I
score my team then once I score my team
I write the good bad ugly so let's just
say the score is 5 all right the good is
the good is these two people have grown
a lot from last year to this year and
I'll put two names down the bat is we
still don't have somebody that knows how
to do that the ugly is this one
department is a disaster this year we
got to do something about this
department great then in this category I
write my three actionable items so what
am I going to be doing I'm gonna do this
I'm going to do that I'm going to do
this now this is tied to numbers and
goals so my goal is to hire three people
to in this department wanted this
department fire this person number goal
number two my gut mind the number that
I'm going to do is I my expectation of
this team is for them to do six hundred
thousand dollars in the next two weeks
whatever the number may be for your
business great there's a goal so every
box will have a number
and a goal tied to it when it comes up
to actionable items so first one is
steam second one is sales flow how's my
cells for looking so I'll go through a
look at the sales cycle right what does
a customer come in once the customer
comes in what options do they have is
they're pretty easy for them to know
what next steps to take do they find
this pretty well do we do a good job of
selling them do we do a good job of
presenting them do we do a good job of
going through the sales flow part do do
the people know the products that
they're selling to them is it pretty
easy do we sell it in a simple way can
it be found easy so I'm going to look
through my sales flow and the sales for
could be you know we have a video I did
it's called how the sales process video
why don't we put a picture what's the
title of that video by the way how to
improve your sales process something
like that why don't we put the link here
so they know what it looks like you can
go find it I look at that sales flow the
sales process on how I can improve it
again same exact thing score zero is one
to ten write down your good bad ugly and
your three actionable items the next one
is systems and procedures so systems and
procedures
what is the system that we have in a
company for hiring meaning when you sit
down and you hire somebody what
questions you ask you to hiring how is
the firing protocol how do we fire
somebody who fires somebody how is the
exit interview what do we do with an
exit interview what opportunities do we
give to them how do we let them go what
is the system when we have a complaint
coming in what is a system that we have
when we have a question coming in what
is a system that we have when we have a
good story coming in what is a system
procedure that we have when we recruit
somebody that we're putting them in a
department that's processing or
compliance or operations or you know
human read what is the system for them
to learn so if I bring a new hire how is
the new hire going to learn about our
company how is the new hire going to be
injected the culture what process do
they go through for orientation
those are my systems in processes then
it the process comes down to you know
areas on the back end that I'm looking
at with the process and the technology
and the CRM and is our CRM doing a good
job can we get a better CRM how is the
software that we're using do we need to
enhance the south or what area the stuff
will be not using at all so make a
listed the 20 different areas in the
software that we use and which ones do
we not use Rankine why do we have these
things why don't we eliminated what can
we enhance these are all questions I'm
asking about systems and processes next
is again by the way you're doing the
same exact thing here scores one to ten
good bad ugly then you want to three
actionable items type two numbers and
goals that is partners I write down
partners how are our partners doing I
keep in mind I have partners here and I
have vendors over here partners and
vendors are different partner is
somebody that I have worked with
generally for three years or more
once somebody I work with for three
years or more who is vested on wanting
to improve the relationship they're
investing money and they're vested and
wanting to improve the relationship that
becomes a partner to me then I'll ask
how's a partner doing with us are they
servicing properly is it getting better
what can we do to make this partnership
better so in the partnership category I
will make a list of all our partners so
let's just say it's five of them how is
this one doing so the scoring on each
one is going to be different because
it's five partners how is it good bad
ugly of each partnership what three
actionable items do I have about each
partnership that I need to talk to them
when I have a conversation with them so
I put that together and then I'll say
this partnership has the numbers gone up
hasn't gone down why has it gone then
it's at our fault it's a ver fault what
is it that they're processes hasn't
improved what are some things they're
maybe not happy with us that we can
improve and how we improved under how we
deliver on our promises I'm looking at
that with our partners that areas that
my expectation of the partners what do I
need to go in negotiate with the
partners what conversations do any time
with the partners I'm having those types
of conversations I'm writing down on
which partners I need to speak to again
that's the other area I inspect next one
customer service how is our customer
service right is our customer service
good are we way too aggressive are we
listening to the customers do we become
too offensive too early is it is it our
way of selling is it a way that the
customer is happy what is the experience
we're given to our customers what is the
words that we're using is it more of a
script or is it more of an X
what is the difference between a
customer service and a customer
experience are we doing a good job
teaching customer experience and
customer service are we doing a good job
taking care of our clients in a way but
that we're getting more referral so I
break that down and I find out about the
five least happiest clients that we had
this year why were they not happy what
did they do
added the five let's just say one of
them was just a rant they just were
unhappy but they're nothing made them
happy and can see the trend everybody is
unhappy everybody is unhappy with that
one client great but the other two had
valid points and these are the two have
questions that we never answered why
don't we call these two let's find out a
little bit more let's let them teach us
about our customer service tell us what
you're not happy about what happened
that we want to learn we wanna improve
would you mind sharing that with us yes
great and then given them something just
to share their feedback with you let's
improve in this area we got to get
better in this customer service area we
rank them we try to improve that this
probably one of most important one one
of most difficult ones because it's an
area you don't have control in but it's
an area that when you run in and gun it
you forget to do this sometimes you need
to do it the sooner you can do the
better in its again same exact it's
exercise one attend get bad ugly three
actionable items brand how's the Brian
Doolin what is a brand mean what is a
market see our brand debts it is
improved is it improving is it getting
into every single household what is the
meaning of our brand
what's the store behind our brand tell
me about the brand we sit down and say
what do you think about when you think
about the company if I were to ask you
what do you think about value tamer what
are things that would come to your mind
what would you say about the brand value
tainment
what would you say you would teach us so
I would sit down in a meeting and say
guys what do you feel about the company
what does the company mean to you can
you tell me what our mission statement
means to you and I want to see the heart
I don't want to see the logical side I
want to hear them because based on their
answer I'll realize men we're too
logical why are we so logical why do we
get away from the initial mission
statement of the company have we
forgotten what it was all about well
then maybe if we forgot what it was all
about then it's my fault I got to take a
responsibility because I'm the leader
what are we doing over here we got to
get better with the brand so then the
same thing with the brand what it means
breaking it down
going into it looking at every aspect of
the brand looking at everything with the
website social media all parts of it
then same thing score one to ten good
bad ugly three actionable items to
improving it next one skills
let me explain skills so skills for me
is not just one-dimensional let me
explain to what I mean by skills so
skills to me is first of all most
importance mean how am I going to
improve my skill set how am I going to
become a better CEO so for instance I
just went to Harvard Business School
there OPM program on a president
management program I was with them for
three weeks and I'm going there next
year in the following three year program
and I'm around everybody in the room
network give or take twenty billion
dollars combined with one hundred forty
four of us out of 14 only fourteen from
America sixty different countries so why
go with there what skills do I need to
improve in okay you know what what areas
do I need to improve it do I need to get
better at operations and find somebody
that strong in operations do I need to
learn the ratios better do I need to
understand the finances better do I need
to understand development better do I
need to understand expansion better what
are some areas I need to improve and a
lot of times the most challenging thing
with skills with you the leader is you
think you're good enough already that's
the biggest challenge I would say you
think you're already there you think
you've already arrived you think you're
already good enough to take a company to
the next level and you're not the
Patrick that got his business to
$100,000 or your revenues couldn't get
the company to half a million dollars he
had to change and improve then a half a
million to a million needs to change at
a million to two million two million to
five million five million to 10 million
10 million or 20 million 21 or 50
million 50 million hundred million there
is a part of recreating yourself right
so skill set starts with myself what I
need to improve it then my main
executives and leaders what do they
individually need to improve it so I'll
take the skill sets of them and really
assess it and sometimes you don't like
doing this because it's time-consuming
but one they will appreciate it so much
that you put time into it too the
company is going to grow
so if you think you're going to wing it
sometimes some people are blinded by
their skills
it requires the coach and the leader say
you have a little bit of a thing here
you got to work on this is not helping
you in your business and the last time
you have to work on as you did your
income went up your business screw you
hit your goal so let's make sure we
don't prove in this area so again skill
starts with me then my main core
executives then my customer service
operations what skills can we improve in
then what area do we need to improve in
on the sales side what area and every
single thing it goes skills how to how
to how to then from that area
I either read the books that we need to
give and assigned to those people an
article a video a movie a speaker a
consultant a keynote it doesn't matter
we need to improve in audacity we go
bring somebody that's about audacity for
instance we brought grant cardone we
need to improve and seeing the vision
about capitalism though we bring
somebody that talks about capitalism we
need to improve entrepreneurship and
seeing that anybody can go from nothing
to somebody Magic Johnson's the keynote
speaker we need to go and improve the
area of management and overcoming
conflicts and all this crucial
conversations we need to figure out a
way to get better and you know dealing
with issues and systems let's go bring
Howard it doesn't matter what it is
we're constantly looking at skills that
needs to improve then figuring out tools
to add to improve the skill set so score
good bad ugly one two three action items
next expansion expansion is what market
you want to get into that you're not in
right now okay you know when we first
started our agency our our insurance
agency we were all in Northridge
California one office sixty-six agents
and we wanted to expand and grow from
one stage to two states so we want to
floor the expansion I said one of our
executives over to Florida right and
then from there when when Chad went to
Florida working with John then we said
how about we go into different markets
then we put our plan of action to get
our strategy together on which markets
we wanted to get into so then we put our
plan of action together and then all of
a sudden one from two states to five to
ten to twenty to thirty to forty nine
where 44 45 states right now by the
entity will be all states right but
that's because we have to talk about
expansion and I see a lot of times
the entrepreneurs sometimes one thinks
about expansion too early and loses the
penetration that he has locally or they
never think about it and they just hoped
it happens accidentally both ways
there's a flaw meaning if you have three
people or five people or small sales
force you don't want to all of us and
spread everybody thin and say you go
over here you go over here we'll go over
you you're all some things like military
you don't want to go to war and tell
your generals you got you know 200
soldiers you tell tango here tango there
tango here tango there it's like 10 and
soldiers went to 10 different places all
of us on 70 got killed because they're
too weak because they face 600 soldiers
in one area you don't want to flank it
like that so you go and expand and take
your army from 102 let's just say 350
then you move 50 right and then you move
so you need to also know about expansion
timing is that the right time for me to
expand is this person ready to go into a
new market are we ready to take this
product into a new market do we want to
go into the state what are the top
metropolitan cities is our product
tailored to a metropolitan city or is
our product tailored to a second-tier
city that we want to get into that's not
maybe a top 20 metropolitan city what is
it so you got to sit and really think
about expansion you got to think about
that then again same exact thing one to
ten good bad ugly three actionable items
and our culture culture every single
year so culture is something that you
know it goes back to the same thing the
culture goes back to brand brand and
culture very similar but to be culture
sometimes the further you get away from
it and you no longer go circulate
amongst the troops culture disappears it
is very important for you to circulate
amongst your troops or the culture to
stay intact so I'm going to sit there
and say what was the culture in the
first year
what is the culture in the second year
what is a culture under 30 and we
continue because the basic thing I'll
tell you like what is the difference
between a cult and a difference within a
culture here's the difference a cult is
all predicated on a cult leader
a culture is no longer predicated on a
cult leader so maybe you went from being
a cult because everything was dependent
on you and you're no longer cult now you
are a culture because the cult leader
can be disappearing and the question is
if the cult leader dies will the culture
continue right and and hopefully there's
been duplication taking place with other
people taking a culture to the next
level
where this is no longer needed it
becomes a figurehead or a voice but the
more you're touching the culture the
thicker it gets and the more social
capital it creates and then there's a
part you're talking are we evolving are
we adapting are we still the same old
sometimes bigger companies their problem
is their culture is a 50 culture where
it's near you were still using dolls
we're old-school with this well maybe
old-school doesn't work because the
person you're trying to attract is not
turn on my old schools are you paying
attention to that so who do you want as
a customer are they going to be
interested in your culture that has an
adapted yet so the culture requires a
lot a lot of due diligence I did a video
once I think it's called 24 ways to
improve your culture build a company go
to build a company culture let's put the
picture again image up here again so you
can see it on how to improve your
culture by the way I get into very very
vivid details on how I worked on the
culture myself compliance boring no
alikes compliance right this keeps you
in business every business has
compliance you got to get the best
compliance people working with you best
of them even when I was smaller and I
was running a sale shop out of a Granada
Hills office and it was not the best
area where we got our office a couple
times it was a drive-by we had a year
what he called legalize a marijuana
joint when they were not only selling
marijuana they were selling cocaine and
other things out of this place so
anybody that would come into our office
you would just smell the marijuana
maybe that's what people bought easily
from us I don't know what it is maybe
that kind of helped out a little bit but
compliance was something I invested in
because it kept me in business sometimes
if you're the market or at your sales
gun you go on a million miles an hour
everything is sells that's just making
its ssssss up and you're not hitting
compliance you're all of us
getting an avalanche of compliance
problems that you need to put up with
two years from now that you could have
solved the sooner you touched upon
compliance so don't skip this too
quickly this is very very critical to
know exactly what compliance issues you
have same exact exercise you need to put
up with compliance and sometimes
compliance will have to do with hiring
new team members keep that part of my
next vendors vendors are people I'm
doing business with that I'm transacting
with I'm paying them their vendor and
I've seen which of these vendors can
possibly become partners and which of
the vendors planning to fire there's a
vendor this year I'm firing I am NOT
happy with this vendor that person is
going to get a personal phone call and
you're fired
because it's just I'm not happy with the
way sometimes vendors and I hope my
vendors are watching this by the way you
know who you are because some of my
partners and vendors some of you guys
watch all these videos and you message
me afterwards and we got the point great
if you're watching these vendors I hope
you're seeing this I love vendors who
have aspirations of becoming partners I
have a very big problem with vendors who
have already done business with you two
or three times and they've gone one
hundred two hundred three hundred
thousand dollars a day let's you say
million dollars a day because you don't
business with them so now they think
it's on would he call it automatic that
you're going to say yes every single
time and they cannot upsell you by 10
percent or 15 percent or just hidden
Commission stuff because you're already
doing business with them I have a very
big problem with that and every time
this has happened someone gets fired
every single time someone gets fired so
vendors I'm looking at which of them do
I need to have a very private
conversation when I tell them exactly
what my expectation of them is moving
forward and I will have those
conversations with vendors I will have
those conversations with vendors and as
sometimes the vendor is doing such a
great job that I tell them I said look
I'm really hoping that we can get over
here and I tell what it's going to take
to go from here to here if we do this
then you become a partner and when you
become a partner you know we endorse you
once we endorse you everybody goes
through and sometimes partners get
demoted to vendors as well by the way
then last but not least is competition
ok competition so competition maybe what
new you know competitors are getting
into the marketplace what is it
barrier to enter today how our
regulations looking for us to go against
the bigger guys what bigger competitors
are buying a presidential campaign or
nominee and funding them because they're
hoping to add a new regulation or a law
that's going to prevent us to compete
with the bigger guys I mean we study all
this stuff you know you don't build a
billion-dollar company Accidental you
need to know that these guys that are up
there the bigger competitors don't want
you to grow their wishes for you to go
out of business listen they're dreaming
you go out of business today you know
who you are you're my competitor you're
watching as many of you watch as my
competitors you are praying we go out of
business today right but we study you as
well we know how powerful you are and
sometimes you got to see who's coming up
from here who's coming up from here
who's getting down who's kind of getting
out of the game who decided to get out
of the certain product that you're in
they don't want to touch it anymore and
why what price point are being sold you
know what is the price point right now
kind of like the comparables what is the
company's value because somebody's
company was so for 17 billion dollars
automatically raises your valuation of
you come all of those things you pay
attention to with competitors which one
of them are calling you who wants to go
from a competitor to a partner some of
these competitors see you and say I
don't want to compete with you man can
we become partners how can we become
partners then you know there's possibly
a relationship there so there's proper
due diligence and investigation it's
pretty detailed here with the
competition side as well and then BOOM
same thing numbers and goals that you do
by the way this once a year takes a full
day once a year takes a full day and
it's well worth it it will make you
Millions if you do it properly this
another time you do six months it's an
overview because you're debriefing what
you did for the full day did you just
recap and go through the points and you
mark it off we need to adjust are we
doing this we're not doing this just one
we highlight which actionable items you
already hid which ones close sending
email saying guys remember earlier this
year we talked about this we are this
far off update update update and I'm Bo
okay so once a year full day second time
inspect email where everybody's at so
everyone knows what the goals are with
this I again
this is a full-day course I can do this
full-day course but I don't this is not
the place to do a full-day course it's a
simply a YouTube a Channel video that
I'm doing for you but here's what I want
you to know about what I did for you is
a couple different things one the video
you this is not a video want to watch
once you want to watch this video twice
you want to watch this video and share
this video with people that are part of
your team especially your executive team
that can also figure out ways how they
can improve their parts of the business
the other area I would tell you to do is
this I have a PDF that I have my team
produce that has this formatting on a
sheet of paper for you to score yourself
then questions underneath it with the
good bad and ugly and your one two three
that you can go print and download for
free there's no cost to it some people
would pay you know hundreds of dollars
there's a lot of online people that
would pay hundreds of dollars for this
purely free you need to go to Patrick
baby be calm or the link is going to be
somewhere here if you're watching this
on YouTube the link will probably be on
the bottom if you're watching this on a
complete different website come to my
website
Patrick Brady be calm and under find
this video just type in inspect in the
search you'll see it Mari let's hop up
with a picture of the inspect button
where the clicks inspect and a video
will come up you'll have a download
downloadable item PDF on the bottom to
see this print it out go through
yourself with your business as you
inspect it then send me a message once
you do this and if you have any
questions or comments or thoughts about
it comment on the bottom and last but
not least be sure to subscribe to this
channel we are this close listen this
close to a hundred thousand subs and we
would not get here without your help and
many of you I personally want to thank
who are getting their entire teams to
subscribe to this we're so excited about
all these projects we have coming up
over the next 36 month bunch of
collaborations that you'll be excited
about but please subscribe to the
channel if you haven't already
mário good catch and everybody else this
is how I inspect my business take
everybody bye-bye
you